in today's eight on your site investors
expect a recession to hit next year tech
companies have already announced
sweeping layoffs but there are certain
careers almost immune to economic
downturns we take a look at the demand
for skilled blue-collar workers
our classes are packed out right now
derrick neismith is the campus director
of nti national technical institute in
henderson he's hiring additional
instructors to accommodate the growing
demand of people who want to sign up for
the three skilled trade programs being
offered electric hvac and plumbing
people are coming to us in
this day and age are uncertain about the
very apparent
recession that may be upon us nationwide
skilled trade programs including
construction and automotive repair
boomed after college enrollment dropped
during the pandemic according to the
national center for education statistics
enrollment in vocational and trade
schools has seen record growth over the
past two decades with the trend expected
to continue the vocational schools which
were once dismissed as where other
people's kids go right where the kids
who weren't as academically advanced
maybe they were just gear heads they
would have all these names
are now schools of choice in fact demand
is so strong for these skilled
blue-collar workers economists expect
trades people will have no trouble
finding work for years to come
obviously a booming time for them
however both electrical environments and
plumbing contractors especially are
constantly reaching out to me for
you know year-round career services
placement of our graduates here at nti
and he has people stuck with no
advancement options at their current
jobs have also enrolled at nti brian